each new horror revealed in ukraine
serves to further harden the west's
resolve against moscow russia
does not have a place
at the table
of countries
who have come together
to maintain global economic prosperity
in washington deputy prime minister
christian freeland called for russia's
expulsion from the g20 after two days of
international finance meetings in which
canada and other nations walked out on
russian delegates support of canadian
people which we see right now is
unprecedented and for that i want to
thank you ukraine's finance minister
lauded canada's efforts including
billions in financial aid loan
guarantees and military support
canada is also discussing reopening its
embassy in kiev following the lead of
several european governments we will
very shortly
next week reopen our embassy in
ukraine's capital city
as the battle for ukraine's future rages
in the east the un is drawing closer to
a firm conclusion that russia has
committed extensive war crimes over
these eight weeks international
humanitarian law has not merely been
ignored but seemingly tossed assange
emerging satellite images of mass graves
in mariupol potentially for thousands of
bodies only add to what the un says are
at least 50 documented cases of unlawful
civilian executions in bucha we are very
concerned we're very worried about
what's coming next the u.n secretary
general plans to visit moscow next week
where he will meet with president
vladimir putin he may also visit keeve
he hopes to talk about what can be done
to bring peace to ukraine urgently
yet there's little optimism it will do
much to bring an end to the conflict now
that russia has made its intentions so
brutally clear jackson prosco global
news washington